we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David p I'm
getting different versions of this question
more and more.
Take a listen to this.
Yeah.
David, this is Brian from Utah.
Um, I was just wondering, you live your thoughts
on, uh, the easiest way of beating Biden in
the Democratic primary would be for review
the Sanders or warrants a drop out.
Okay.
Uh, maybe the consolidate the progressive
vote.
Uh, it's just kind of, seems like they're
taken away both from each other.
Um, anyway, I just wanna hear your thoughts
on that.
That would work if that's okay.
Good idea.
And how would that play out?
All right, thank you.
Yeah.
So listen, I'm getting this different versions
of this question more and more.
If Bernie drops out, Warren gets his support,
crushes Biden.
If Warren drops out, Bernie gets her support,
I understand the implicit logic of it.
They are the two most progressive candidates.
Therefore, certainly if people who like Bernie
can no longer support Bernie because he's
out, they'd go to Warren and vice versa.
The polls don't bear this out.
There seems to be a very demographically aligned
second choice for both Bernie and Warren.
The pleura from the last poll I saw on second
choices, a plurality of Bernie voters would
go to Biden if Bernie were to lose or leave
the race, a plurality of Warren supporters
would go to Camilla Harris if Elizabeth Warren
were to lose or leave the race demographically.
That makes sense.
Ideologically it doesn't make sense and we
need to account for that.
So if people have other polls that suggest
different trajectories for Bernie voters and
Warren voters respectively, if the two candidates
were to lose or leave the races, their respective
races, let me know.
But from what I've seen, it is not mathematically
obvious that either Bernie or Warren abandoning
these races would lead to a consolidation
of support around the other candidates such
that they would surpass Joe Biden.
If Bernie Bales, it may actually boost Biden
more than Warren.
If Warren Bales, it may boost Harris more
than Bernie and Joe Biden may still be in
the lead, which is why I think we should be
cautious about assuming that the path forward
is for one of the two Bernie or Warren to
say I'm out in order to help the other person.
Now if if they left and said, please support
x.
If Bernie said I'm getting out, please support
Warren or if Warren said I'm getting out,
please support Bernie.
That may change the dynamics, but that is
not what the polling for now seems to suggest.
Disagree with me.
Have contradictory polling data.
Let me know.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the conversion therapy
group founder who has come out as gay and
apologized.
We will talk about Democrats continuing to
want to look into Donald Trump's hush money
payments to mistresses and we will talk about
a non drinker who is wrongly charged with
driving under the influence who has now picked
up a nice settlement from a New York City.
All of those stories and more on the bonus.
So become a member@jointpacman.com or a patron
at patrion.com/david Pakman show to instantly
get access to the world famous [inaudible],
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.